I fake new CNN's credibility continues
to be called into question today during
an interview on the liberal network
president Trump's attorney Rudy Giuliani
called out the entire network for their
blatant bias what's this does the
president never get there any benefit of
the doubt was Eucharist every Rudy or on
this network
which is disgusting actually I would
tell you something I think he gets the
benefit of the doubt much more often do
you know they know your credit for you
know that most people think that I'm
crazy to come on here unfair to the
president do you think this interview
has been unfair yeah I do you think this
interview has been unfair absolute why
because I don't think he'd given me a
chance to explain how injustice this
case is I don't think you've given me a
chance to explain the basis of it with
the FBI report that was faulty the FBI
report that came to the conclusion can
be prosecuted when you come to a
conclusion do anything wrong I mean how
can you investigate a man who will you
come to include anything wrong you guys
never never you didn't play up that part
of the report now Rudy Giuliani's right
fakeness en and basically never gives
this president a fair shake they never
will there not even honest about it now
for example earlier this week CNN Trump
hater official Trump hater supposedly a
reporter supposedly objective Jim Acosta
he goes on Jimmy Kimmel Live and he said
he was just as tough on Obama as he is
on President Trump it's not a joke
take a look are you their least favorite
of all probably yeah you know as FDR
once said I welcome their hatred I do
and you know listen when I covered
Barack Obama I was just as tough on him
people might not believe you weren't
dating like you either
they don't like me adversely disliked I
am
so how a constant can actually say that
with a straight face is beyond me
because the tapes don't lie and our
friends at the Media Research Center
they found this gem of Jim Acosta
covering President Obama's inauguration
in 2013 the only thing missing from the
so-called reporter are the pom-poms take
a look and obviously this is this is the
moment that everybody is waiting for on
inauguration day when the president
would first ladies step out of their
window and walk down Pennsylvania Avenue
you know I feel I feel like I should
pitch myself right now wolf I can't
believe I have this this vantage point
of history in the making
but here literally what about 15 20 feet
away from the president I'm probably a
good I would say 50 feet away from the
president right now
yeah with Obama needs to pinch himself
and he says he's a reporter says he's a
journalist no he's a liberal activist be
honest about it now earlier I spoke with
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders about this and so much more all
right Sarah thank you for joining us
you know you look at all of what I'm
pointing out here I don't think there's
ever been a more hostile news media in
the country then there's been the
president Trump I think it's obvious
it's it's it's so bad that there is 91%
negative coverage according to the media
Research Center it's unreal the amount
of negative coverage that comes from the
media covering this White House not just
because it's so one-sided but because
there's so many good things that they
could be talking about the economy's
booming Isis is on the run remaking of
the judiciary getting rid of the
individual mandate the foreign policy
and the relationships that this
president has built every single day
there's a good news story to tell and
yet 90% of the coverage is negative Sean
one of the clips that I hope that you'll
go back and watch that I think Jim
Acosta also said from that interview was
that he'd love to go one-on-one with
President Trump I just a little note to
Jim I think he should stick with going
one-on-one with me because President
Trump is way out of his League and I
don't think he wants to take on that
challenge because he's definitely not
going to win III think that the media
bias is out of control and he's
certainly one of the leaders of the pack
look if he wants to be an opinion person
I'm a talk-show host and as a talk-show
sometimes I do straight news interviews
sometimes I give opinion other times I
moderate debates sometimes I debate it's
all encompassing but I am I tell
everybody I'm a conservative we still do
a lot of we break frankly we break more
stories than most of them in a in a week
than they do in a year in my opinion and
they've been wrong so often what why why
does this continue in this sense every
day I watch you I don't know how you do
your job I could Nick there's not enough
money on this earth to pay me to do what
you do and it's actually gotten personal
and abusive and
I have we gotten to the point where
maybe they should submit their questions
in writing hand back written answers
because all they're really trying to do
is get a moment so they can show their
audiences how tough they are and it's
really just a It's Showtime for them
it's not about getting answers look I do
my job because I love this country and I
love getting to come to work every day
and work for President Trump who also
loves this country and wants to do good
things you can block out the critics and
focus on the people across the country
that love the president love what he's
doing and we try to spend our energy
focused on those comments and the people
and the voices coming from outside of DC
and outside of New York and outside of
the Talking Heads because those are the
people that really matter and those are
certainly overwhelmingly supporting
President Trump and what he's done and
that makes it pretty easy to come to
work every day you know look at this
week the president was answering
answering a question about the violent
violent gang known as ms-13 it was
obvious the media ran with it and then
they ended up almost all of them having
to retract it there's a lot of
retracting that they really need to do
though it's it's incredible and a lot of
times you see the media just
automatically assume the worst out of
this president which is really sad
because again I think they're missing
out on some of the most amazing things
that are happening he's had an
incredible first year and a half and
they're missing it because they're so
focused on being negative and attacking
not just the president but everyone
around him and I think that's a real
disservice to the country he clearly was
talking about ms-13 when he referenced
the animals and I said it yesterday I'll
say it again I think he could have gone
even further these are some of the most
despicable people that have ever walked
this planet the things that they do the
type of activity they engage in animal
is the nicest thing I think that the
president could have called them and I
hope he'll continue to call them out and
continue to put pressure on every
law-enforcement agency and official in
this country to bring them down and
protect people across all over the
country and certainly I think he's done
a great job doing that
all right sir great job I don't know how
you do it every day amazing and we
appreciate you being with us